hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr seht es bereits im Titel
eingeblendet denn ich zeige euch heute
die besten minecraft 1.9 10 seeds
das hier ist der erste seed ihr seht
oben rechts mal eben eingeblendet sieht
doch schon hier geht gerade wunderschön
die Sonne auf wirklich klasse wie
Minecraft Aussehen mit dem shade das hat
genau in dem Moment hat gerade geguckt
aber sieht wahrscheinlich daran weil
sich die Welt hier gerade noch aufbauen
ich habe nämlich gerade den seed neu
eingegeben das hier ist tatsächlich äh
der beste sieht in Minecraft 1.19 in
meiner Ansicht nach ich finde aber auch
Sachen schön die andere glaube ich gar
nicht mal so schätzen würden denn wenn
wir hier runterspringen seht ihr schon
das ist alles Wasser
wir starten also das da oben ist
wirklich der Spawn wir starten genau
hier wo überall Wasser ist
dementsprechend können wir direkt mal in
unserer creative Modus Inventar gehen
und zum Eichenholzboden nehmen und
einfach mal hier so ein bisschen
rumfahren denn ihr seht schon mit dem
Shader das sieht wundervoll aus die
kannst du einfach hier durchs Wasser
fahren die ganzen Spiegelungen und hast
einfach eine riesiges Mangroven Biom
heißt das glaube ich was man hier
entdecken kann hier sind unfassbar viele
Fische man kann überall mit dem Boot
lang fahren da wir uns allerdings im
Creative Mode befinden kann ich euch
auch einfach mal die Größe dieses bioms
zeigen indem ich einfach mal kurz hier
hoch Fliege und ich einfach mal so ein
bisschen zeige wie riesig
dieses Biom wirklich ist
das ist alles voll mit Wasser und da
ganz hinten
und doch unter anderem dort vorne wenn
es sich selbst aufbauen würde
hallo Ada
haben wir auch noch einen Dschungel der
auch extrem selten ist in Minecraft es
gibt bei diesem seed allerdings noch
andere Sachen die man entdecken kann wie
zum Beispiel hier so eine hexenhütte da
kann man auf einmal ganz gut reingehen
hallo
na schön dann nicht ähm wir haben hier
auf jeden Fall noch so eine hexenhütte
die sich auch in der Nähe vom spawne
findet da vorne ist dass man grofen und
was wir tatsächlich auch noch haben hier
vorne haben wir tatsächlich auch noch
eine Pyramide die so ein bisschen
versuchen ist in der Wüste allerdings
haben wir hier vorne dann auch noch so
ein savannenbiom oha
seit wann hat Minecraft so riesige Berge
also hier Vornamen riesigen Berg wir
haben links daneben auch noch ein Dorf
und wenn man an dieser Pyramide vorbei
guckt sogar noch mal so ein riesigen
Berg wo so ein Dorf so halb drin
versunken ist also sieht auf jeden Fall
sehr sehr wild aus ich bin immer so ein
bisschen neugierig in Minecraft ihr
kennt mich ja ich liebe auch Minecraft
für die ganze Ästhetik und generell wie
es aussieht einfach schaut euch das an
die sieht aus
wie Lego mit einer schönen Grafik und
dann auch noch mit dem Shader und sowas
alles es sieht sehr sehr geil aus ich
möchte natürlich wissen was ich hier
unten drin befindet nicht ob er das
wieder eine drüber dann sind wir da auf
der Ding oha guckt mal sogar zwei
Diamanten goldene Apfel haben wir hier
drin das haben wir hier drin eine Menge
Gold auf jeden Fall hier dann haben wir
ein Buch mit Band 5 und hier drin haben
wir tatsächlich auch noch zwei Emeralds
also wenn das kein krankes dann weiß ich
auch nicht wir schauen uns jetzt
allerdings bereits den zweitens sieht
für das heutige Video an und ich bin da
mir noch nicht ganz sicher ob wir die
Sache die ich euch zeigen möchten möchte
direkt am Spawn haben allerdings sieht
der Spawn auch schon extrem krank aus oh
doch haben wir direkt wir haben hier
nämlich eine riesige Landschaft am Start
mitten in verschiedenen Blumen ihr seht
schon hier ein riesiger Haufen Scheiße
jetzt bin ich dann immer nicht so schön
an Minecraft wenn dann hier einfach alle
so ein Krams einfach in der Luft fliegt
wenn wir uns allerdings einfach mal hier
drauf stellen seht ihr schon dass wir
hier vorne eine riesigen See haben wir
haben dann dort vorne hinten so eine
kleine Grünfläche hier vorne so ein
bisschen Sumpf alles im Wasser
eingehüllt da vorne ist es im Dschungel
nee es ist nicht das ganz normales
reichen Biom und dann wenn wir links
rüber schauen riesige Berge bestehend
aus Sand Kies ist Steinen Erde hier
vorne Birken Eichen keine Ahnung was das
für Bäume waren und hier einfach
generell alles voll mit riesigen Bergen
ich flieg mal ein bisschen Weg und zeige
euch das von weiter weg hier vorne ich
sehe das auch schon ich sehe ich sehe
hier schon seh'n Strandhaus
schaut euch das mal an
von Minecraft kreiert
diese Berge dieser Ausblick nach
dahinten guck mal wie das aussieht
und dann schaust du hier links
und sie ist einfach das hier so mit dem
Wasser
diese heftigen Berge kommen hier noch
mal kurz ein bisschen durch wie schön
dass sie das auch aussieht mit diesem
lilianen die darunter hängen wie wie
Minecraft sich einfach entwickelt hat
über die Jahre ich meine ich zock das
Spiel ja seit 10 Jahren mittlerweile
fast schon früher gab es das alles nicht
das ist einfach alles einölig aus das
ist alles so aus eigentlich in Minecraft
und jetzt mittlerweile
hast du ja auch für eine Fauna erstmal
was sie für Tiere rumlaufen guck mal da
vorne so ein kleines Häuschen drauf
bauen ey wie süß dann hast Du hier
direkt wenn du dich umdrehst das einfach
so eine fette Landschaft kannst dir so
ein bisschen rumfliegen hast übelst
schöne
Gegenden schau dir das mal an auch hier
was ist denn das
du hast hier Sonnen fetten Berg soll ich
da vorne ein Ozean da vorne den Fluss
geht runter und hast hier so eine Höhle
stell dir vor du kommst aus der Höhle
raus spawnst irgendwie vielleicht hier
unten fliegt nach oben denkst du nichts
Böses
fliegst sie an den ganzen Bäumen vorbei
und siehst so eine Landschaft
ey wirklich
ich weiß nicht ob ich der einzige bin es
ruckelt auch hier schon wieder weil das
wahrscheinlich so krank ist das alles zu
laden gerade für meinen PC aber ich weiß
nämlich der einzige bin aber ich finde
minecraft ist wirklich und ich meine es
wirklich ernst das schönste Spiel was es
gibt auf diesem Planeten wir gehen
allerdings direkt weiter zum drittens
zieht den ich euch heute vorstellen
möchte meine Damen und Herren und zwar
ist das einfach ein Vulkan in Minecraft
natürlich klar es ist jetzt kein
richtiger Vulkan sowas gibt's in
Minecraft leider noch nicht allerdings
sieht die gleich schon was ich meine ich
habe die Koordinaten schon vorbereitet
ich glaube wir sind allerdings guck mal
wo wir allein schon Spawn also ja wir
sind schon da
der Vulkan war eigentlich 200 Blöcke vom
spawnen entfernt habe ich mir
aufgeschrieben aber
ey schaut euch das an
was ist das für ein Berg was ist das für
ein seed Leute du spawnst direkt neben
einem Dorf wo die ersten Häuser schon
stehen mit Tieren und denkst dir schon
so boah krass der Berg ist schon heftig
aber dann schaust du links rüber und
siehst das hier
was geht ab für jeden der dieses Spiel
nicht feiert der vielleicht einfach so
ein CoD Mensch ist oder der einfach sagt
komm Autorennspiel oder keine Ahnung was
der wird diese Faszination Minecraft
nicht verstehen aber für mich jemanden
der seit dem Start von Minecraft mit
dabei ist guck mal was du da hinten auch
noch sehen das sind ja auch noch so
fette Berge hier vorne will ich auch
schon denken was ist denn das für ein
Kranker Berg aber das hier
was ist das bitte für ein seed es hat
gerade schon wieder geruckelt weil es
wirklich enorm krasses was sie glaube
ich geladen werden muss da vorne sind
wir gesprochen ne hier vorne drauf genau
da sind wir geboren und hier vorne ist
einfach ein Vulkan in Minecraft wir
fliegen mal nach ganz oben und schauen
uns mal um meine Damen und wir lassen
Dich auch gerade relativ viel drin weil
ich einfach unfassbar schön finde ihr
kennt sie einfach in Minecraft Sachen zu
entdecken sich das einfach anzugucken
guck mal der höchste Punkt hier auf dem
Vulkan ist Höhe 255
[Musik]
alter Schwede
oh mein Gott ist das irre ist das das
ist im Dschungel da vorne auch noch
nicht das ist ein Dschungel mit dem
ganzen Bambus das heißt ihr habt auch
noch direkt einen Dschungel am Spawn
schaut euch das mal an
das ist das verrückteste Open-World
Spiel der Welt hier vorne des Biom kenne
ich nicht mal das ist irgendwie in
Minecraft Lukas Staffel 1 da waren wir
ja gar nicht hatten ja nur so eine Insel
einfach solche Sachen das habe ich ja
alles gar nicht gesehen schaut euch das
mal an
[Musik]
ey wie verrückt ist es wenn man sich
hier oben eine fette Butze drauf baut
[Musik]
ey ich bin wirklich sprachlos ich habe
mir zu jedem sieben noch so ein paar
Sachen aufgeschrieben wo beispielsweise
sich so ein ozeanmonument befindet oder
wo sich ein Gemeinschaft befindet oder
eine kranke Höhle oder sowas aber das
hier reicht
[Musik]
das reicht
das ist der also know Job das ist der
krankeste sieht den ich je in Minecraft
gesehen habe und ich weiß für vieles ist
heftig wenn sie sieht sehen so mäßig ja
äh da haben wir irgendwie so einen
kranken
Diamanten Vorrat in der Höhle direkt am
spawnen ich weiß ich habe schon häufiger
mal Minecraft sieht Videos gemacht aber
für mich ist sowas einfach das krasseste
sich solche Landschaften anzugucken und
es wird ja alles innerhalb von Sekunden
von eurem Computer völlig random
generiert
[Musik]
diese Welt klar wenn man ihn sieht einen
gibt dann haben wir die natürlich den
hatten dann auch schon weitere Leute auf
der Welt aber diese Wende einfach auf
generieren Klicks bei Minecraft
irgendwer war mal der erste der diese
Welt einfach sich generiert hat
irgendwer war mal der erste der hatte
diese Welt einfach am Start oder dachte
sich nichts Böses und hatte plötzlich so
einen Vulkan vor sich
das ist doch nicht normal dieses Spiel
das kannst du doch wirklich keinem
erzählen wir befinden uns jetzt
allerdings auch schon im vierten sieht
meine Damen und Herren ihr seht ihn
jetzt mal oben eingeblendet ist ein ganz
ganz lange Zahlen Kombination ihr spawnt
genau hier und hier sieht auch alles
tatsächlich schon wieder sehr sehr nice
aus wir können mal so ein bisschen
rumfliegen ich kann euch mal zeigen wo
man hier nämlich spawnt in seiner
Mischung aus dem Eis Biom und hier vorne
mit so Birken hier vorne die äh der
Wasserfall generiert sich gerade sehe
ich noch ähm es sieht auch hier sehr
sehr wild aus schon mit den ganzen
Bergen und den ganzen
Situationen hier Situation die Sache ist
allerdings und die möchte ich euch
zeigen habe ich mich auch schon mal
sieht doch sehr sehr geil aus ne
schon wieder sehr sehr wild aus aber
darum soll es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
gehen sondern um diesen Ort hier
der ein oder andere wird natürlich schon
erkannt haben wir haben da vorne eine
Pyramide am Start sieht doch sehr sehr
wild aus ich wusste gar nicht dass es in
Minecraft mittlerweile in der Wüste auch
diese komischen Büsche gibt das habe ich
ehrlich gesagt noch nie gesehen da
müssen wir einmal ganz kurz eben
hinfliegen wäre mir wieder ein paar
Ruckler weil ich mich sehr sehr weit weg
teleportiert habe ihr seht die
Koordinaten oben mal eingeblendet als
wichtiger vorbei Idiot das sind Bäume
die in der Wüste auch stehen aber im
Wasser oder wie sind sehr sehr cool aus
äh na ja da hinten haben wir auf jeden
Fall auch noch eine fette Insel
allerdings geht's hier darum dass wir
hier vorne einmal eine Pyramide haben
dann werden wir weiter fliegen seht ihr
auch schon dass wir dort hinten ein Dorf
haben in der Wüste und wenn wir dann mal
ein bisschen links fliegen seht ihr auch
schon dass wir hier vorne noch ein Dorf
haben das sind leider nicht der
allerdings nicht die einzigen Sachen die
wir haben denn dann hier befinden halb
vorgebautes Portal natürlich die Wüste
auch generell nicht so riesig wir haben
hier überall andere Biome Grenzen
allerdings geht es primär heute um das
hier bei diesem sieht
das ist nämlich eine der tiefsten
Schluchten die zumindest ich jemals in
Minecraft gesehen habe
schaut euch das mal an
da oben geht es runter wir schauen mal
einmal ganz kurz auf welchen Koordinaten
wir uns da befinden wenn man F3 drückte
Minecraft kann man das ja immer ganz gut
sehen wir befinden uns nämlich wenn wir
oben stehen also wirklich ganz oben hier
am Rand zack befinden wir uns auf Höhe
62 und wenn ich jetzt mal runter gehe
wirklich komplett runter meine ich damit
ihr zack
[Musik]
die Schlucht komplett bis zum Ende sind
wir auf Höhe -44 100 Blöcke geht diese
Schlucht runter
und was diese Schlucht alles beinhaltet
nicht nur ein lavafall sondern hier
vorne auch noch irgendwas Neues was ich
auch noch nie gesehen habe ich bin wie
gesagt noch nicht in der 1.19 so
wirklich unterwegs gewesen das sieht
irgendwie was ist denn das jetzt haben
wir so grüne Erde und Höhlen ist das
überhaupt Erde moosblock Moos ist das
okay willst du leuchtbären die hatte ich
mit Luca tatsächlich auch haben wir
tatsächlich unter der Erde wir haben
hier vorne Sand oder was ist das hier
nee das ist tot okay Ton haben wir hier
am Start äh das geht da vorne noch
weiter guck mal was ist denn aus den
Höhlen geworden das sieht ja irre aus
mittlerweile allerdings auch ganz
normale Höhlengänge hier vorne in den
Seiten drin und das ist wirklich irre
also sowas so eine Schlucht habe ich
einfach noch nie gesehen in Minecraft
hier vorne geht's auch noch unendlich
weiter also das ist wirklich sehr sehr
geil an diesem See und damit kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zum letzten seed für
heute meine Damen und Herren gerade mal
oben rechts eingeblendet die Zahlen
Kombination könnte er einfach falls ihr
euch mit Minecraft nicht so gut auskennt
einfach eingeben bei der weltherstellung
und dann bekommt ihr genau die Welt die
ich euch zeige die Koordinaten werden
wir euch auch alle ein hier äh werden
wir euch allerdings keine Koordinaten
einblenden denn das hier ist der Spawn
und ich zeige euch einfach wo es lang
geht ihr müsst nämlich einfach vorne
wieder durch dieses Mangroven Biomen
durchlaufen beim groven Bäume die hat
mir auch bei Skyblock mit Luca und läuft
dann einfach hier an so einer Wüste
vorbei so ein bisschen da gibt's schon
interessante Strukturen das
interessanteste kommt allerdings es gibt
wirklich eine Menge seeds in Minecraft
wo es darum geht hey hier hast du 20
Diamanten am Spawn oder ach guck mal da
hinten haben wir also sogar eine
Pyramide oder beispielsweise Mensch äh
wenn du hier lang läuft dann hast Du
relativ schnell Dorf oder kranke Höhlen
oder irgendwie es gibt ja mittlerweile
Minecraft 19 Minecraft Version 1 von 19
auch so krasse Sachen in die Richtung ja
äh da gibt's dann irgendwie neue Boss
und keine Ahnung was was ich aber viel
interessanter finde sind immer solche
Sachen
boah das ist gerade krank oder mit der
Sonne
das finde ich viel interessanter in
Minecraft wenn sich sowas erstellt wir
sind da vorne gespannt
ich bin extra schon so rüber geflogen
dass ich nur diese Richtung guckt weil
ihr seht ja schon hier ist ein übelster
Schatten was das hier ist schaut euch
das mal an
das hier ist das Thumbnail das ist das
Thumbnail Leute das sieht ja unfassbar
aus
wie das Ding dahinter der Sonne schaut
euch das mal an wenn das sogar noch so
halb dahinter ist
oh mein Gott genau das ist das dann ey
ich könnte heulen ist das schön
wirklich schaut euch das mal an ich
finde es immer irgendwie mehr Zeit
zeigen wenn man auch so die Hand sieht
und das Inventar aber schaut euch das
mal an
die Lava baut sich da gerade noch auf
ruckelt natürlich wieder ein bisschen
und es ist einfach so ein wie heißt es
Monolith heißt es glaube ich es ist
einfach random in dieser Welt drin so
ein teil
ey ich liebe dieses Spiel ich kann es
nicht in Worte fassen wirklich dieses
Video sollte eigentlich 8 Minuten gehen
ganz entspannt ich zeige euch fünf seeds
ich wusste aber nicht dass ich hier so
gefallen daran finden würde ich ich
liebe Skyblock mit Luca und dieses
Projekt wo wirklich aufs minimalste äh
hinausgezögert werden um irgendwie was
daraus zu machen aber ich liebe es auch
einfach Minecraft Welten zu entdecken
schaut Euch das hier mal an
wir befinden uns auf Höhe 240
ergebt euch das mal
der Ausblick von hier oben
das ist irre weiter als hier kann ich
gar nicht gucken weil meine Ränder
Distanz nur soweit eingestellt ist Leute
ist
ich liebe dieses Spiel stellt euch den
seed hier nochmal ein das ist mein
absolutes Highlight ich finde auch jeder
sieht das mein alter ihr wisst ich liebe
Minecraft wir schauen uns noch mal von
unten an der Stelle würde ich das
heutige wieder dann allerdings auch
beenden Freunde wenn es euch gefallen
hat und mir hat es wirklich sehr sehr
sehr doll gefallen wenn das gerne einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen schick dieses Video an alle
eure Freunde die hier Minecraft spielen
weil ich glaube Winter ist immer so eine
Minecraft Zeit da wird man dann
plötzlich mal wieder eine Woche richtig
süchtig und zockt mit seinen Kollegen
auf dem Server und wenn man sowas sieht
echt ich liebe dieses Spiel haut rein
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen was